There are two basic approaches to congestion control.
End-to-end congestion control and network assisted congested control.
In end-to-end congestion control the network provides no
explicit feedback to the senders about when they
should slow down their rates. Instead, congestion is
inferred typically by packet loss, but potentially also
by increased delay. This is the approach taken
by TCP congestion control. In network assisted congestion control
routers provide explicit feedback about the rates that
end systems should be sending in. So they
might set a single bit indicating congestion, as
is the case in TCP's ECN or explicit
congestion notification extensions, or they might even tell
the sender an explicit rate that they should
be sending at. We're going to spend the
rest of the lesson talking about TCP congestion control.